[Musique]
mon père a eu un cancer quand j'étais
enfant
un cancer qui débarque dans une famille
comme vous pouvez vous en douter ça fait
l'effet d'une bombe
mais ça c'est l'ong de choc longue de
choc de départ qui n'est pas si longue
finalement comparé à la suite
alors tous les parcours sont différents
pour mon père la suite a duré 8 ans 8
ans à vrai dire pas si malheureux des
bons moments même des vacances en
famille des sorties avec les copains
mes premiers amours ma première cuite
j'ai mon bac j'ai mon premier appart
bref une vie d'adolescente comme les
autres ceci dit on ne peut le nier
au dessus de cette vie d'adolescente
comme les autres années le cancer de mon
père alors je suis très partagé sur ses
huit ans de ma vie parce que dans le
fond et tu as les plus terribles où les
plus beaux les plus terribles oui c'est
sûr à chaque anniversaire on se demande
si c'est les dernières bougies qu'on va
souffler avec lui il y a les analyses il
y a les ambulances il y a que la maladie
avance et que c'est dur parce que même
si votre père redouble de projets
d'avenir à ce moment là bas vous savez
que ça va se terminer mais les plus
beaux aussi sans doute parce qu'on sait
aimer dans la famille à ce moment là
beaucoup aimé alors c'était avec des
larmes parfois avec passion souvent mais
mon dieu quand c'est aimer
au bout de huit ans nouvel attentat
j'apprends que mon père est décédé alors
ce n'est pas du tout une surprise pour
moi à ce moment-là je m'y attendais mais
les symptômes sont les mêmes qu'au
départ c'est la bombe
je me souviens de ce que je faisais
quand mon téléphone a sonné je me
souviens d'avoir compris tout de suite
ce qui se passait avant même que ma mère
est il besoin de le dire
et surtout je me souviens de tous les
regrets qui ont débarqué à ce moment là
1 pourquoi je n'ai pas pris le temps
d'aller le voir une dernière fois
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai pas osé lui
dire papa tu vas me manquer est-ce que
j'aurais pas dû être là pour sentir son
dernier souffle est-ce qu'il n'avait pas
besoin de moi à ce moment là bref c'est
des regrets qui sont menacés et même
s'il s'atténue avec le temps je vous
assure que ça vous suit toute une vie et
s'il ya bien une chose que je crois
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut tout faire
dans la vie pour s'éviter ce genre de
regret avec les personnes qu'on aime
aujourd'hui géré équilibré mais normes
familiales sans cette béquille qu'est un
papa alors parfois ça penche un peu oui
mais j'ai plein de nouveaux tuteurs qui
viennent soutenir mon pied de tomate et
franchement ça va quelques années plus
tard je discute avec un ami qui me
demandent où vivent mes parent ce à quoi
moi je répond de façon tout à fait
quotidienne que ma mère j en charente et
que mon père lui est mort d'un cancer
réponse immédiate de mon ami a désolé
mais enfin enfin désolé de quoi est-ce
qu'il était responsable du décès de mon
père n'ont a priori non est-ce qu'il
était désolé de m'avoir fait dire la
vérité mais bon ça si moi ça me gênait
j'étais capable de le dire tout seul
c'est à pardon à désolé à excuse moi
qu'est ce que j'ai pu les entendre sur
mon parcours
les gens pensent bien faire mais ils
sont maladroits parce que avec ca pardon
et compagnie vous fermez la conversation
vous empêcher la personne de continuer
sur le sujet bon il faut dire pour la
défense de mon ami que je venais de lui
balancer en une phrase deux gros tabou
pour beaucoup de gens dans nos sociétés
occidentales à savoir la mort et le
cancer vous même dans la salle est
peut-être en train de vous dire pour la
nana nous parle depuis moins de quatre
minutes et elle nous a déjà balancé une
dizaine de fois le mot cancer est mort
ouh là là on va s'amuser
bon vous en faites pas je compte pas
vous laisser partir le moral dans les
baskets
ceci dit moi quand j'étais enfant j'ai
souffert de ces tabous parce qu'il mène
au silence
c'est des moments de sa vie on a
vraiment besoin de mettre des mots sur
ce qui nous arrive où on attend une main
tendue mais elle arrive rarement cette
main parce que justement les gens
évitent d'aborder ce sujet avec vous de
peur de vous brusquer alors oui moi j'ai
souffert de ce silence
aujourd'hui je n'en veux plus à mes amis
c'est pas de leur faute c'est de la
faute de la vie et puis avec du recul
j'ai compris que voilà peut-être que le
cancer de mon père m'a fait grandir un
peu plus vite que d'autres sur certains
sujets et surtout j'ai compris que quand
on est dedans on n'a pas d'autre choix
que de regarder que de regarder la
réalité en face voilà une réalité qui
vous rappelle que pas que vous n'êtes
pas éternelle que la vie est éphémère
oui quand vous perdez une personne que
vous aimez profondément en plus de créer
en vous le manque l encre en vous une
certitude celle que vous même allez
mourir un jour alors connaissant mon
parcours et mon franc parler à ce sujet
certains de mes amis viennent me voir et
me disent mon écoute malo j'ai appris
que que telle personne avait un cancer
et moi je suis complètement dévasté je
sais pas comment aborder le sujet avec
lui et moi ma réponse à ça c'est
toujours mais mais vas-y vas-y avec ta
gènes ne te censure pas parce que ce qui
est gênant dans le fond c'est d'être
gênés par ce que tu ressens ça s'apaise
ça ça sonne faux
tu seras sans doute maladroit dans tes
premières questions tu fera sans doute
des erreurs dans les premières choses
que tu vas dire mais si la personne que
tu vas voir sans que tu es là pour elle
que tu viens là pour l'erc pour elle
alors elle ne t'en voudra pas tes
maladresse et sans doute elle te
remerciera d'avoir fait le premier pas
attention à ce que je viens de dire cela
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut insister
lourdement si la personne en vous devez
en face de vous n'a pas envie de parler
vous la laissez tranquille vraiment un
cancer qui débarque dans une vie c'est
ya des moments d'ouverture et puis
d'autres où on a besoin de rester avec
soin pour soi mais mes seins je n'ai pas
envie de parler aujourd'hui
ça veut pas nécessairement dire je n'ai
pas envie de parler avec toi en
particulier un moment donné de ma vie
j'ai fini par être clair avec le décès
de mon père j'avais plus de rancoeur
contre l'avis plus de colère plus de
manque au quotidien ça veut pas dire que
j'ai pensé +1 aujourd'hui encore alors
que ça va bientôt faire dix ans il
m'arrive encore de pleurer voilà quand
je vois ma fille de deux ans par exemple
et que je me dis que jamais je lui
présenterai son grand père ça c'est un
peu dur mais finalement c'est des larmes
de souvenirs qui me qui me rassure
presque parce que je n'ai pas oublié
avec le temps et c'est tant mieux mais
bon voilà j'étais au clair avec ça
j'avais fait mon deuil et je me suis dit
que j'allais me servir
ce parcours je me suis dit que dans le
cadre de mon métier d'artiste j'allais
essayer de dire au monde ce qui s'était
passé dans ma tête à ce moment là et ce
dont j'aurais eu besoin et ce dont
d'autres certainement avait besoin
aujourd'hui je suis donc 1 re partie à
la rencontre de personnes atteintes de
cancer de leurs familles de leurs
soignants des femmes surtout les hommes
étant moins partant pour me livrer leur
histoire allez savoir peut-être que les
hommes aiment moins parler bref c'est
une autre question
ceci dit j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
évoluer pendant un mois dans un service
oncologie d'un établissement de santé
j'ai entendu plein d'histoires toutes
très belles mais effectivement pas
toujours drôle je me suis pas marrer
tous les jours je crois que les
personnes qui m'ont le plus ému à
l'hôpital c'était souvent les familles
des accompagnants les proches des
malades m'ont souvent fait part de de la
difficulté qu'ils avaient à sentir
impuissant incapable de sauver la
personne qu'ils aiment en colère même
souvent contre l'avis de ne pas les
avoir choisis eux à leur place c'est une
place un peu bâtarde parce qu'ils vivent
la maladie également mais plutôt en tant
que spectateur je me souviens d'un mari
qui avait comparé son rôle
d'accompagnant à l'accompagnement de la
viande
voyez il se sentait les légumes qui sont
retour voilà le faire valoir la
garniture mais jamais le plat principal
ça fait vraiment des déséquilibres
notamment dans les couples il ne faut
jamais oublier les accompagnants c'est
très difficile pour eux aussi je
pourrais aussi vous parler d'une
rencontre que j'ai faite d'une femme que
j'ai trouvée mais tellement belle et
elle est gracieuse magnifique toujours
avec le sourire
c'était une mère de famille sa maladie
était très avancée et elle savait que le
reste de son existence elle ne vivrait
toujours sous traitement
sa maladie s'était propagée dans ses os
et elle vivait en permanence avec une
poche de morphine pour soulager la
douleur ce qui était assez frappant pour
moi c'est que c'est que voilà j'avais
une femme quand même y avait une maladie
avancée mais mais il y avait une vraie
dichotomie entre ce qu'elle vivait et
son attitude alors oui ces mots était
dur mais c'était pas difficile à
entendre temps on sentait qu'elle était
dans l'acceptation du cycle de la vie
alors effectivement elle m'a fait part
de moments de colère quand elle planter
des bulbes dans le jardin et qu'elle ne
savait pas si elle allait les voir
fleurir
ou quand son mari lui faisait des
projets d
de vacances pour l'été prochain et
qu'elle ne savait pas elle si elle
serait là pour le voir l'été prochain
mais d'après ses dires c'est est vite
passé parce que dans le fond la colère
ne servait à rien et que ça changerait
pas le cours de son histoire
je crois que les personnes qui
approchent de la mort où une chose
fondamentale à nous rappeler la valeur
de la vie je crois que trop souvent nous
oublions qu'il y aura une fin à notre
histoire et je te crois que ce n'est pas
grave que cette fin existe que c'est
normal que c'est naturel des milliards
d'êtres humains ils sont passés avant
nous et on continue à se reproduire sait
déjà qu'il doit y avoir un intérêt à
vivre avant de faire le grand saut
certaines femmes m'ont fait part de
leurs impressions de grandir en humanité
grâce à leur cancer oui j'ose le grâce à
leur cancer et moi je crois que nous
devrions apprendre à faire grandir notre
amour de la vie avant que ça ne soit la
vie elle même qui nous y oblige
bon pour remonter un peu l'ambiance des
histoires j'en ai entendu beaucoup et
d'autres dont pourrait qualité égale
qualifié la fin de reuze également une
jeune fille de 25 ans par exemple que
j'ai croisés et six mois plus tard je la
retrouve dans la rue traitement fini les
la tête plein de projets de voyage
d'avenir de chant de reconversion
professionnelle une femme à qui on l'a
dit on a quand même diagnostiqué un
cancer rarissime incurable avec une
espérance de vie très courte et sans
traitement et qui me raconte son
histoire vingt ans plus tard en pleine
forme
bon comme quoi on a toujours le droit
d'y croire moi dans la vie je suis
comédienne et metteur en scène
j'ai la chance d'avoir un métier qui me
demandent de qu'il donne le devoir même
de réfléchir sur notre humanité
ils me donnent également beaucoup de
précarité mais il veut donne ce
formidable de voir voilà maintenant cinq
ans que mon équipe et moi-même annonce
ses paroles que j'ai recueillis à
l'hôpital de salle des fêtes enrôle
d'hôpitaux en salle de spectacle il est
arrivé très rarement que des personnes
sortant colère de la salle de la salle
de spectacle et moi quand cette colère
arrive je crois qu'il ne faut pas la
négliger et qu'il faut la respecter
mais ceci dit la plupart du temps nous
assistons à des rires et à des larmes à
l'unisson c'est tellement incroyable une
salle de spectateurs qui vibre ensemble
que ce soit dans les reer ou dans les
larmes vous partager quelques minutes
d'humanité avec des parfaits inconnus
chose que vous aurez rarement dhr le
l'occasion de faire dans la vie de tous
les jours aller au théâtre c'est
important
allez voir du spectacle vivant ça aide
justement à le rester vivant alors vous
risquez de tomber sur des choses qui ne
vous atteignent pas mais quand la magie
du théâtre vous tombe dessus
je vous assure ça vaut le coup d'être
vécue depuis cinq ans maintenant donc
agi la fin de chaque représentation le
même phénomène s'installe les gens
restent les gens se parlent ils se
racontent leur histoire celle d'un père
d'une mère d'un instituteur d'un mari
d'un voisin les gens s'écoute pas de
plus bel applaudissements à mes yeux que
celui-ci pour ma part je pense que les
halls de théâtre devrait d être des
lieux toujours aussi étudié que la salle
de spectacle en elle-même ce qui s'y
passe à la sortie entre les spectateurs
et aussi important que ce qui se passe
pendant la représentation
je crois qu écouter des histoires est
bon pour la santé mentale ça et duke
ça a été les jugements tous les soirs
nous lisons une histoire à ma fille
avant de l'endormir alors j'avoue il ya
des jours où c'est un peu la corvair
parce que la journée a été longue
parce que lire quinze jours de suite son
histoire préférée du moment ça va hein
la nôtre trop aime les spaghettis c'est
bon mais c'est un véritable rendez vous
dans la journée des enfants adorent
qu'on leur raconte des histoires ça les
apaise adultes on sait pas ce qui s'est
passé on s'est dit qu'on n'en avait plus
besoin
pourtant on en a plein à portée de main
peut-être que nous aussi ça nous
apaiserait d'écouter des histoires
entendre l'histoire de l'autre pour
avoir moins peur de l'autre moi
j'aimerais entendre toutes vos histoires
comme vous êtes en train d'écouter la
mienne prenons des risques ne restons
pas dans nos bus il faut nous mélanger
même si nous ne sommes pas toujours
d'accord même si nous ne comprenons pas
toujours comment l'autre peut penser et
agir ainsi je sais que ce n'est pas
facile mais essayons parle on discute on
écoute on l'autre pour comprendre
l'autre je sais que nous sommes pour la
plupart emmitouflés de certitudes sur
les gens et il m'arrive d'en être la
preuve vivante
mais chaque rencontre est capable de
déconstruire un préjugé si on accepte de
trouver du bon dans l'autre je crois
qu'une croyance neissen que lorsqu'on
lui offre la possibilité d'être remise
en cause pour faire avancer notre monde
il est indispensable de faire que de
faire croître notre connaissance à
propos des des gens qui le peuplent
alors
cherchez soyez boulimique de
connaissances réfléchissez comprenez
vous avez toute une vie pour ça je crois
que vous avez compris le sens de mon
message je voulais juste finir en disant
que oui je sais que j'ai un métier qui
me permet d'entrer assez facilement en
contact avec des personnes d'autres
sphères que la mienne ceci dit les
prétextes sont toujours bons et pas si
difficile à tourner à trouver si on se
creuse un peu la cervelle je sais pas
moi allez allez discuter avec votre
maraîchère au marché de ces cultures
cette année prenez le temps de faire un
sourire à votre boulangère et par l'état
plus du beau temps fait du covoiturage
invitez votre voisin de palier
l'avantagé du covoiturage c'est que si
la personne en face de nous et vous
embête a en face de vous et vous embête
vous pouvez au bout de deux heures ne
plus en entendre parler le voisin d'en
face c'est vrai que c'est plus compliqué
de s'en débarrasser après mais voilà
fait du covoiturage c'est prévient voilà
je je crois qu'il vous fait tout ça vous
vous sentirez vraiment bien après et que
le monde qui vous entoure ne s'en
sortira que plus léger et je crois qu'il
est temps de nous rencontrer de nouveau
merci
[Applaudissements]